george how are you oh
my god i'm talking to conan
o'brien yes hello have you been doing tv
now
28 years 28 years yeah and this is my
first
time ever talking to you that's right i
am
so elated i'm so happy i'm
finally conan you got five minutes ago
after 28 years i get five minutes you
got five minutes to go
all right here we go listen i need to
talk we just live in the same building
in new york city that's right
you should said 28 years ago you said
come on do the show that's been 28 years
ago
yeah and um i guess you were pissed at
me because i lived on the top floor
you lived here i lived in a very a nice
building on the west side and you lived
on the top floor and i lived down
down where they put the irish people
down near the bottom
so i was very i was very bitter about
that uh but yeah i used to see you all
the time
and i remembered you'd go on dave's show
all the time dave letterman's show
all the time i used to go on dave
letterman show with a pad
and uh with my you know uh so long ago
with my yellow pad i could still keep it
with me
i conan i didn't know i've been doing
comedy so long people are accusing me of
stealing my own [ __ ]
in 1993 i used to take the pad on
television i went on arsenio hall and i
said i got some new jokes here
it might be funny might not i got to do
let him on tomorrow night i got to make
sure this stuff is funny
wait so you would try your material out
on arsenio
to see if it was good enough to go on
letterman that must have pissed off
arsenio
maybe it did i didn't care the thing
about it
the thing about it when i would do the
joke i would say you know and people
accuse me of stealing this and i did
this in 1993. yeah
i would do a joke the joke would work
real good i just write down
joke works real good i do the next joke
joke works real good
right next joke needs work
needs work i do the next joke real good
fourth joke i do jokes funny audience
sucks
they would go crazy and just that's how
i became
uh to be the guy with the yellow pad the
legal pad because if you don't put them
on a real legal yellow pad
the jokes are not legal it doesn't
that's not it's not legal i know that
i you know what my method is i test the
jokes and on every one i say crowd
sucked it's never my fault it's always
crowd sucked
nothing wrong never my fault it's funny
yeah you know it's funny and we have a
we're so blessed to be able to do funny
business especially this day and time
uh to be able to um make the world laugh
and i just think that's
great and i'm so blessed to do what i do
uh with this epidemic going on and
and all i do you know i'm just blessed
all i do is just lie
i just lie i got the greatest job at all
i just make up [ __ ] and they pay
me that's you're right it's funny i
never thought about it uh
jokes are just they're pretty much just
lies we're just
we're just bullshitting we're getting
paid we're very lucky people